So we said deep learning is our attempt to replicate.
the human brain
of course the brain that
we have understood up to this point in time.
Let's first start with the most Atomic the most
basic component of a new life so up
here we have
a diagram or a pectoral model of a
neuron
so this is the most building block basic building block or
in organic component of the
of the human brain, right? We don't want to go down to subatomic particles
and that kind of thing.
So this is a neuron it has these.
Let's say branches called the dendrites that
receives signals.
electrical chemical signals from other neurons
and these signals travel down these dendrites.
And then they are processed by this thing called a nucleus.
If the signal is strong enough.
Then another signal will travel down this Axon.
and out to these other
terminals
and it is at these terminals where we
have connections with other neurons.
So the way we are able to learn things and remember things is
by these electrochemical signals.
firing off
all of our brain
and so we have these neurons come together to form thoughts to
form memories to form ideas.
Okay.
Well, you see here down here is a very abstract diagrammatical
representation of the above.
But we want to do is a mathematically model this neuron.
And deep learning we call the neuron.
the perceptron
So in our brain we have neurons in machine deep
learning we have these things called perceptrons which are supposed to
be.
replicas
Of the neuron that's a perceptron.
so the dendrites
here are the inputs. What are the inputs?
The inputs are the dimensions.
Or The Columns of the data.
If you if you think for example about
an Excel sheet I can use that real estate example.
Size of the property distance to the city center number
of bedrooms.
These are all columns right column vectors.
And each column Vector is an input.
And what's the circle that circle is the well, I'll
show you what the circle is. It's a combination of two things, but it will
be processed here.
and then one
value or one vector will be produced.
from this
N number of vectors, so it's a linear transformation in other words and then
here at the axon you have the option of either
outputting one vector or branching out to three
why?
Do we want to have one of the other world depends on how we have struck to
do neural network?
Let's look at a more mathematical representation of this model and
it's this.
here we have x sub 1 all the way to x sub n
where X for each x sub I
represents a component
of some Vector x sub I
we notice the excess here are I thought
so again to use a real estate example.
let's say x the vector x sub 1
is the
number of bedrooms
and then x sub 1 could be three bedrooms.
Then the vector X up 2 could be the size of the property in
square feet.
So this will be
2,000 square feet
Right, so this could be three three bedrooms two thousand
square feet.
So basically all of the
values of the first property
then we have these W. Is anyone know what these W's are?
Any guesses what w stands for?
Precisely the weights right? We said that
these are all factors that influence the
price of the property.
but
the number of bedroom the size of the apartment the
floor.
Of the apartment.
Whether it has a balcony or not.
It's proximity to the city center. These are
all important factors, but some are more important
than others.
Right. So for example being close to city center
is the most important factor.
So for example, if x sub 3 is the proximity to
the city center, then it will have a much higher weight.
Whereas let's say x sub five, which
is the
I don't know the lighting system, right?
if it's
if the use fluorescent instead of LED
It's a very insignificant. It's something you can change, you
know in an hour or two, but let's say for example
the factor.
It's it's it will have a much smaller weight.
What you do then is you take the product of each X and
its weight.
And then you sum.
So you have product product and then some of the products?
That's the summation here.
And then that value that you will get will be the activation.
now
this activation will be fed into what we call an activation function.
and an activation function is basically
a function that will determine
the threshold of the signals if the signal is strong enough.
We'll pass it on to the next.
perceptron otherwise
We will not send any signal we send the zero.
For example, why let me give you an example why you would
need to choose an activation function why you would need to
process a signal or not?
Imagine you're looking at a picture.
and let me pull up a picture here picture of a
character
any character doesn't matter.
And we want to know
what is the number?
in this picture
the way we're going the way the model is going to look at this picture is
to go through the entire picture and of
course if you remember from session,
I think our very first session we said that pictures will
be represented as a matrices, right? This will be a matrix.
And then we said a white pixel is 255.
And a black pixel is zero.
So if we for example look at this.
Section of the picture because we have to go.
from one corner to the next
and process the picture
one super pixel at a time
a super pixel of the collection of pixels
If we look at this super pixel, everything is white.
There's nothing of
there's nothing here. So it's activation will be zero.
There's nothing worthwhile.
However, if we make our way here.
Well now we will have a positive activation.
Because we have a line. That's the idea. That's the purpose of
this activation function.
and when we use this activation, we
will be able to narrow down our
we will have another linear transformation.
We will only have the number four and you will
discard the area around.
And then later on what we will do is we will flatten this
Matrix. We'll have another linear transformation.
Where we'll go for example from a 16 by 16.
to a
single vector
So 32.
1 by 32 vector
Now why why do we need to do this new transformation we'll come
back to to the state has to do with distributions. We will leave that
for later.
Well what I want us to First understand is this the main
component of the neural network perceptron.
Now why is it called now work? Well, because it's a network of
perceptrons.
if you take
those
and I think I was demonstrating something. That's
why I have this here and give it up these.
Sorry about that.
if we take
Those perceptions and put them into an hour. We will get a neural network.
So all of these circles that you see here.
These are all perceptron perceptron all the
perceptrons.
It's called Deep learning because you know, we have
these layers.
And they can if we stuck.
Enough of these layers will have a deep network of perceptrons.
So that's what's called Deep learning.
And this is an example of a fully connected Network
and it's called fully connected because every perceptual is
can it's connected every other perceptron in the
subsequent Network.
Run us are all the leaders in this example are then
yes. See this densely. There's all that's correct.
now in a neural network
and a fully connected Network now there are different.
Combinations and why you would choose one
combination versus the next?
We'll have to do with the nature of data. Is it pictorial?
Is it sequential like if you want to do Time series?
Time series is where for example like
stocks right the price of the stock.
Goes up and down.
or the weather
You want to see why does the weather go up or down?
And if you could predict it for the next
month or the next?
week
well, the change in temperature is associated with data is
associated with the
Calendar right obviously several it's warmer when
there is cooler.
or another example is against speech to
text or
Other complete, you know, when you go to Gmail and you type in an
email say for example, hello, Ron.
Please see thee and then Gmail completely remaining
sentence. It was a CD attached.
It will like fill in the blank. It will complete your sense.
That is also accomplished using.
a sequential Network
So again, I'll show you different Arrangements. I'll show their pictures
of them, but
there are different ways we can assemble this.
But here again the if you see here, we have the input layer then we
have.
A series of hidden layers and then finally an apple layer.
Now why this is how four for
example, let's say you are doing again one more
time. I'll do the real estate example. You have all
of the features of the property.
And then you're going to learn every single hidden layer
in here.
Is going to learn a weight.
Basically on one thing I forgot to mention here.
These weights are randomly assigned.
Because the model does not know.
The significance of the number of bedrooms versus the
significance of the proximity to the city center to
the model. These are all numbers that mean nothing.
So it will first randomly assign weights and
then using a what we call.
back propagation
and a technique in
Multiverse calculus called gradient descent. It
will adjust the weights.
Basically, it will make one round of prediction
compare it to a sample.
And then it will adjust the weights because if you remember we
talked about MSC in our last Workshop. We
said that we want MSD conversions you have to convergence
is zero, then what the model predicts and what
the actual prices are will be equivalent. If
the errors are 0 they will be equivalent and that's what
we want ideally.
Initially the model when we first feed the data to the
network the MSC will be large.
But the model will keep looking at the sample again and again
and again and adjust the weights.
I adjust the weight again and again and again and again until it has
understood why one feature is important by other features not
important.
Now again, if you're just trying to predict the
number you'll have only one output.
Which will be the price.
if however we're doing something like
see RNN
a convolutional new network where you're
going to go from a matrix data.
to a
to a Vertex to a vector
if you're going to be doing this transformation, this is a linear
transformation. Then what what you will append at
the end of the outpole layer could be another Network. You can actually mix
two networks together especially for complex problems.